let's jump to this story from timgas.com
new 2024 polls show Biden alternating
alternately tying with and sliding
behind Trump despite the possibility of
four separate sets of indictments
support for Trump remains strong this is
bad news they say a key strategy for
Biden's election bid will be branding
trumpism and Maga threat to America
casting Trump supporters as far right
authoritarians as access described let
me also add personally one tactic of Joe
Biden is to criminally indict his his
opponent because clearly he can't win
legitimately interactive polls show that
Donald Trump is beating Biden by three
points among moderate independencies of
nine in swing States Trump is up nine
this is bad news for Joe Biden and may
explain why they're so desperately going
after Trump with these indictments
because Trump's going to win and you
know we had people we had a you know
Liam last night he was convinced Trump
could not win because the Deep state
would not allow it to happen and I'm
just like they allowed it in 2016. that
is like is that is that the argument in
2016 the Deep State went like oops Trump
won maybe I think so because the way he
was saying and what I agree with is that
now that he said when I get back in all
of you in the Deep state are going to be
fired they're like okay this isn't the
Trump from 2016. now it's a different
guy with a different motive and I still
don't think it means they're powerful
enough to stop him from winning they can
certainly throw roadblocks in the way
and try and go up against him and
criminally charge him right yeah but it
does not mean look his polls are gonna
Skyrocket because of this his
fundraising is going to Skyrocket
because of this they cannot stop him
they're making they're playing the game
in desperation they're thrashing about
as they drown well the reality of it is
is all this propaganda and the fake
indictments wouldn't be necessary if
they didn't think he could win they
would just leave him alone exactly and
so what I see with this is as we have
tremendous victories with say Bud Light
and things like this on cultural fronts
and sound to Freedom they are going for
the only thing they have left which is
raw government power they are losing
culturally their shows are getting
roasted
alter alternate Independent Media is
starting to rise Bud Light Lost a
quarter of its market share from
endorsing this stuff not popular nobody
likes it Trump is his popularity is
going up he's improving in the polls the
only thing they have left is
truncheons
do you think that if we replaced a lot
of the people in the government that it
would work better you think it's a
problem is Personnel or is it structure
both eliminate
hold on you you replace a lot of people
it'll be better for sure you eliminate a
lot of positions in departments and
replace people we can fix the problem
yep
it's just like with the FBI you can't
just get new people you need to gut the
agency figure out what powers they have
what powers they don't so and then they
can't go out on a rampage like they have
been the past two years again but let's
uh let's add into the mix the other
question in this presidential debate
if Trump is indicted and removed will
Ron DeSantis be the nominee and uh
ultimately let's just uh let's just talk
a little bit about where Rhonda
Sanchez's campaign is at and my friends
the latest reporting that's come out
about Rhonda Santos's campaign is I'll
call it heartbreaking because I think
back to the promise we saw with a Rhonda
Santos campaign somebody who was pushing
good culture War policy who was uh
pushing a lot of the same policies As
Trump but with more attacked Youth and
vigor and then Ron DeSantis
burned it all to the ground and I and I
do hold him personally responsible I
understand that it's his PR and
Communications team that are ultimately
syncing everything around him but the
fact that he has not fired Christina
Pasha at this point despite every insane
error she's made he's just like nah keep
doing your thing even though he's
collapsed in the polls he's basically no
longer even in the race well you saw the
the statement that like the internal
statement that was leaked of what was it
hit the brakes on what doesn't work hit
the gas on what does it's like they
think you would hit the brake on
Christina pushball because this is
clearly not working for this campaign
who said the historius was that the
Santos himself it was it was the
communications director you know
basically sending it out to the
influencers this story from semaphore
about Ron DeSantis blew my effing mind
the video with the son in red the black
sun was made by his campaign
outsourced the video to a third party
and the dude who made it retweeted they
fired him through under the bus
this is the the the the anti-lgbt uh I
shouldn't call that the the video they
made criticizing Trump's stance on LGBT
issues made in-house outsourced so they
could have plausible deniability the the
the video in which Ron DeSantis is
appearing before a spiraling Nazi son
and rad symbol with Soldiers with
soldiers marching towards it was made by
a camp by one of their I believe he was
a campaign staffer
and then
sent to a third party and retweeted and
we have it here check this out
the scoop senior aides of DeSantis
oversaw the campaign's high-risk
strategy of laundering incendiary videos
produced by their staff through Allied
Anonymous Twitter accounts a set of
internal campaign Communications
obtained by some of four reveals the
videos include two that have that have
created distract uh recurring
distractions for his campaign
check it out they say screenshots of the
war room chat reviewed by some before
included staffers praising a widely
derided and since deleted video
originally posted on an anonymous
account Ron DeSantis fan cams that
included a version of the Sun in rad a
symbol associated with Nazi Germany
quote this belongs in the Smithsonian
wrote Kyle lamb the campaign's director
of racism Data before the video blew up
in the campaign's face he was among the
38 staffers laid off in recent weeks
amid a campaign reset messages viewed by
semaphore also Show members of the War
Room group actively sharing images to
put in the video while it was in the
editing process though not the Sun and
red symbol that was in the final version
the big the big issue here that I want
to bring up to check it out the campaign
is never publicly confirmed or denied
ownership over the LGBT and sun and red
videos which staffers retweeted after
they were posted by Anonymous accounts
they recently fired one Aid Nate Hockman
who shared the latter video and
according to an axios report created it
Tim cast has reached out this is a a
while ago to the Santa's campaign to
have someone come on the show for a
polite normal discussion and they refuse
I I was just thinking I think Ron needs
less social media presence but more
focused honest stuff but then I'm like
well why am I thinking that when I think
of Vivek ramaswamy I think more social
media more everything you're doing even
if they knock Trump out I don't think
DeSantis has a chance I mean after
everything his campaign is just crashing
and burning day by day worse and worse I
think Vivek is is the guy I mean if if
he steps up Vivek seems like a much more
optional candidate
here's the thing with a vague
someone will accuse him of something and
then he will outright address it or make
a statement and nobody else is doing
that I mean with the wef stuff with
everything he came out and then when
Trump was raided he came out and said
this is unprecedented we can't allow
this he's the only one doing that I'm
gonna I'm gonna tell you exactly what I
think by the Santa's campaign and uh I'm
sure I'm gonna piss off a lot of people
but I'm gonna say it anyway
I'll tell you what my view is
the the some Trump individuals I don't
know who or what the deal is posted a
photo of DeSantis team and there was a
picture of Christina Pasha with rug
burns on her knees as if to imply
something untoward about her
this is around the time this whole thing
got kicked off where all of a sudden de
Santa supporters just started rabidly
snarling and spitting in people's faces
I think she was emotionally slighted
triggered to the point where she started
using the DeSantis campaign as a vehicle
for emotional satisfaction against the
people who insulted her I think you're
completely right and the same thing
happened again when I think it was uh
Alex brusa was he released a picture
which was clearly a meme uh with
push-pot and then it was George sorosity
Nixon which was clearly photoshopped
there was a picture where it was like in
the background yeah it was like a
clearly photoshopped George Soros it
wasn't even a good Photoshop and then
they just went rabid on everybody it
seems like and what happens is you've
got a handful of people who are like
Trump influences or whatever who played
dirty or whatever and so their their
response is to attack any and everyone
who dare insult them or even question
them in any way the fact that you know
what what we've seen with the reaction
you know Mike cernovich tweeting about
it how the DeSantis campaign has just
started attacking everybody
you know having talked to a few other
people not Mike but a few people about
what it is it seems that Christina Pasha
initially everybody were they were big
fans she was working with Santa she was
she was going for the media she was
calling out their BS and then this rug
burn knee thing happened and all of a
sudden it was just like
I I look I get it it's like really
insulting condescending demeaning
misogynistic whatever you want to call
it but that was the moment where it
seemed like something flipped and now
anybody who had a bad word to say was
just getting bitten was just getting
spat on and slapped around for it
doesn't matter they declared war after
that well and after this there's no way
that the DeSantis campaign can succeed
because you just marginalized and pushed
away all these people that are loyal to
Trump these people that yeah if Trump
gets knocked out they probably would
have voted for DeSantis but why would
they vote for him now when they've
essentially just been I mean hitting on
them over and over again there's this
like a pro DeSantis account that appears
to have like an AI deep fake Avatar or
whatever has been promoted Max snored
well that's that's got a Family Guy
character yeah but this one made a like
deep fake audio thing of me praising
Christina Pasha and I'm just like these
guys have to be Trump supporters because
the only the only outcome of doing
something like that is to try and get me
angry so that I insulted a Santa's
campaign but I could but uh and that's
why I'm like this has got to be a trump
supporter you like make
false flag DeSantis and trick them into
promoting things that hurt their
campaign or a Biden supporter because
absolutely yup make sure the tennis
can't win but then I gotta tell you I
gotta tell you if Ron DeSantis won't
fire Christina peshaw it doesn't matter
if it's an intended to sink his campaign
or not the man cannot deal with his
campaign he cannot operate a campaign
it's good that he fired the people he
fired but I can tell you this I know
some of the people you fired should not
have been fired some of the people that
he fired he should have promoted and
fired the senior staff instead of he
laid off some like 38 people I know some
of them and I know they're smart and I
know they understand everything I'm
saying but they're the ones who got let
go Ron DeSantis in this capacity has
failed miserably and the person who's
led the charge the whole way as they've
just crashed and burned he won't fire
well their messaging is absolutely
terrible I mean they're keeping the
people that are like look at like Jeremy
Redfern I think that's his name right
after Ashley Babbitt was shot and killed
uh you know he came out essentially
praising it he said f around and find
out and it's like the messaging does not
align with anybody that supports Trump
so how do you expect to Garner these
votes with keeping these people on your
campaign I think we're learning
something about Rhonda Santos I think
we're learning that he barely won the
first in the first place in Florida
Trump's support helped push them over
the edge how did he win so well I was
warning about this too everyone's saying
Rhonda Sanders is such a good leader
that he won by a million votes to a
certain degree I agree with that but I
also wanted to point out as I have since
the beginning you also had Mass Exodus
from many other states of right-leaning
people or more libertarian leaning
people who went to Florida because of
the policy and were guaranteed to vote
in this direction and then people can
say yes but that was Rhonda Sanders's
leadership fair I agree
I will add however it was unobstructed
leadership because the legislature was
on his side so he had a clear path to
Rolling these things out when it comes
to a campaign he can't fire the people
who have failed
no every day it gets worse at this point
maybe he can recover I'm not saying he
can't but when you look at all the
polling data I can't remember who the
one one major polling agency said at
this point in a primary race no
candidate polling at these numbers has
ever been able to turn it around
oh I think his campaign sunken I don't
think there's any recovering into this
point it's it's it it it's it kind of
makes me sad one expression oh yeah well
especially after because I don't think
he did good in the uh in the Tucker
interview either where he was
interviewing the candidates he came off
as a neocon I mean he just seemed like
he was kind of a Warhawk throughout that
entire interview and seemed disingenuous
but then you know you have vivec and I
think he did the best out of anybody up
there he was honest the entire time and
his message resonated with people but
every other candidate and even DeSantis
I mean after I watched that I was off
the DeSantis train completely because I
was like I don't think this guy actually
believes in what he's talking about I
will I will say this because we got a
super chat this guy Nathan C says to
Santa's campaign is fine you guys are
projecting for sure I don't even believe
the story the video came from his
staffer any name proof yes Nate hochman
and I can confirm personally that I have
spoken with people within the
descendants tennis campaign and Hawkman
did make the video don't believe me
don't care I am telling you that's where
I'm at because I got on the phone with
people like come on we've been in the
space for a very long time we know many
of the people who went to work with Ron
DeSantis in fact I have DMS with with
the people in his communication staff
and we'd invite him on the show before
but as soon as his campaign started they
win full corporate neocon locked down
told their people not to appear on this
show because we were critical of them
and I reached out and I said
did this guy do it
he did it
it's publicly known it's publicly I
fired the guy well they threw him under
the bus but but this is all publicly
known I mean this is in semaphore and
axios I don't believe it but look if
you're gonna sit there and be like this
is clearly not true it didn't happen yo
they deleted the video and fired the guy
like come on yep sounds about right I
thought they did it I sound sounds like
a leftist just denying basic reality at
this point and you know I I understand
loving Ron DeSantis and everything and
trying to back him as your candidate but
there's evidence on all of these things
there's there's uncountable evidence I
have a lot of faith that Ron would come
by the couple weeks after he started
announced and play ball like shoot some
hoops and then do the show for a couple
hours and it would have been awesome and
we'd see the real guy hear about his
family what his dreams are for the
future what he did before College all
that cool stuff that you want to know
about a guy if you're going to entrust
him with that kind of power to represent
you on the geopolitical stage but
unfortunately week three went by week
four went by week five went by they put
out that gross deep fake and and then
I've just kind of lost I have zero Faith
now in Rhonda well you look at the
difference too like socially wise
engaging not just with audiences on
stage but engaging with supporters and
fans of you Ron DeSantis is so awkward
in person when he does this he clearly
has no care in the world to engage he
doesn't have Charisma when he's engaging
with his fans he'll just say two things
and then he'll walk off and go do
something else but then Trump I mean
he's sitting there you know signing
Medal of Honor pictures going to fast
food restaurants buying people food he
resonates a lot more culturally yeah
Santa's was a VP pick DeSantis wanted to
be the big dog he should have been the
VP he could have been the VP to Trump he
could have been he could have been the
the the the the the easy going guy the
younger guy that would have helped
Donald Trump get the votes especially
from Suburban women and things like that
instead he says no I'm gonna be the guy
I'm not a number two guy
well now I don't think he's ever going
to be the guy even in Florida again I
mean at this point well I mean he's
turned out yeah I mean he's he's going
to be done in politics I think I think
this is a career killer for DeSantis
because you try to take the helm from
clearly who was the nominee and there's
no question about it instead of just
playing ball and helping the country uh
you know in a state of I would say great
need thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time